[Music]  things seem to be heating up between  Kourtney Kardashian and unis Benjamin  Pierce Kourtney straddling her 24 year  old model bo on Friday while sporting a  pair of denim jeans and a sexy Calvin  Klein bra and panty set the steamy  Instagram pic may look familiar  remember Kylie Jenner and ex Tyga posing  shirtless in a nearly identical way for  a photo shoot ahead of his birthday  well 38 year old Kourtney has yet to  stop packing on the PDA with unis on  social media from their sexy Halloween  outfits to dancing under the moonlight  court case seems to be living her best  life with her man we really had the best  time ever  recently the couple documented their  road trip together driving along the  California coast stuck in the middle of  nowhere  looks like they eventually touchdown  somewhere nice where Kourt enjoyed  breakfast in bed with a skyline view  [Music]